hi everyone
i'm maury samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism and on behalf of yipsa
and the whitney humanities center it's
my great pleasure to welcome you to the
first event
of our benjamin and barbara zucker
webinar lecture series this year
which will be devoted to exploring the
relationship of anti-semitism
to anti-blackness and other forms of
prejudice
we have a superb lineup of speakers
planned who will guide us in a
conversation
about the challenges that jews blacks
asians
muslims and other minorities face in
common and about the differences that
divide us
please make sure to sign up for our
mailing list on the website for the yale
program for the study of anti-semitism
so you receive our webinar invitations
and feel free to publicize these far
and wide just a few words before we get
started about how the event today will
work
our speakers will talk for about 30
minutes at which point they will
start taking questions from the audience
please submit your questions
anytime during the presentation using
the q
a function at the bottom of your screen
they will only be visible to me
and i will submit them to speakers the
chat function
is disabled the audience uh will also
remain muted throughout the event
uh and we'll we'll finish uh around 6
p.m
so it's my great pleasure to introduce
uh
today's speakers first anthony russell
um here he is is a vocalist composer and
arranger
specializing in music in the yiddish
language
this work is brought him to los angeles
philadelphia boston miami new york
toronto montreal
london berlin copenhagen warsaw krakow
tel aviv
symphony space in new york city and the
kennedy center in washington dc
anthony's work with the klezmer trio
pass resulted in convergence an ep
exploring a century of african-american
and ashkenazi jewish music
anthony lives in massachusetts with his
husband rabbi michael rothbaum
next we have jeff melnick here's jeff
jeff teaches american studies at the
university of massachusetts boston
where he spends a fairly large
percentage of his time these days on his
work as a member of the faculty staff
union executive committee
in his scholarly life he has written a
number of books
including two in the arena of black
jewish relations
a right to sing the blues
african-americans
jews and popular american popular song
and black jewish relations on trial leo
frank and jim
conley in the new south most recently he
published
creepy crawling with the manson family a
cultural history of the legacies of
manson and his followers
at president jeff is researching a book
on race and youth culture in boston
in the years following public school
integration in the 1970s
i'm extremely grateful to both anthony
and jeff for helping us
launch our series and the title of their
discussion today
is shifting affinity's cultural
investigation of the black jewish
relations paradigm
so i will now hand it over to jeff and
anthony
um first i think i'd like to establish
my own observations of certain
underlying dynamics
of the american black jewish relations
paradigm
namely a cultural rhetoric of
trans-historical connection that imbues
so many discussions of the relationship
between
black and jewish populations in american
space
i feel like it's an underexamined
historical circumstance
that specifically two disparate
diasporas happened to meet on american
soil
and of course not just the diasporas but
the general rhetorical baggage each of
those diasporic identities entail
concerning loss of homeland peoplehood
prophetic narratives concepts of
redemption and freedom
and the like with specifically
biblical cultural rhetoric as far as
black people are concerned
i've encountered certain jewish
interlocutors who call this phenomenon
an appropriation which i think is a
misguided term in this case
as jewish texts and narrative tropes
were originally imposed on
enslaved black people under duress as a
part
of the hegemonic dictates of colonial
christianity
i do feel that it is very much in
keeping with the general ways of being
black in the world
that something that was imposed on black
people as an establishment of order was
summarily
turned into an article of
self-determination and freedom but
that's a whole other conversation for
another day
coming from the jewish side in the
maggod section of the passover haggadah
is the following statement
whoever expounds on the story of the
exodus at length
is worthy of praise so
there is of course a halal dimension to
this statement
the mitzvah is not merely in knowing
about the exodus but also in speaking
about it and expounding upon that
narrative
so i'd like to make the contention that
perhaps when
jews encountered the phenomenon of
formerly enslaved people in the united
states
culturally rhetorically there
was this quality of black people as
living expositions
of the exodus narrative because of that
black people have become a site
of jewish projection identification and
even perhaps
naturalization of historical jewish
suffering on the american soil
rhetorically black people almost exist
as an
atavistic enacter of nascent peoplehood
after the ravages of systemic oppression
a narrative most famously sketched out
of course in the exodus narrative itself
i think this is partly why facile and
reductive comparisons of the respective
socio-economic trajectories of black and
jewish people
are invoked oftentimes by jewish critics
because
there's this pre-existing notion
somehow these two groups of people are
somehow intrinsically related
even when their respective outcomes are
diametrically
opposed this is spelled out much more
explicitly i think
when we look at the history of black
cultural expression
and genre consumed and eventually
produced as extensions of jewish
expression
as a sort of cultural rhetorical space
of establishing both jewish connection
and
very importantly jewish distance from
black people
in american social and cultural space
um and i'm very lucky to be talking to
jeffrey because this is something about
which he's written about
quite ably
amazing so i'll jump in there um and uh
first of all thank anthony
for being the the one to kick this off
uh thank uh
everyone at yale who organized this and
uh thank all of you
who are who we can't see but are so
grateful um are joining us for this
conversation
so you know this is like um uh probably
a kind of standard move to make but but
one of the things i always try to do
when i talk about um
black jewish relations is sort of start
and anthony's already
begun this conversation open up this
question about
what we mean when we use that phrase and
something i tried to do early in my
career
is replace the phrase with a different
phrase which of course
couldn't possibly work the different
phrase i wanted to introduce was black
jewish relatedness
as opposed to black jewish relations
because there was a conflation that
happened
and anthony as i said anthony's already
begun um to lay this out for you
there's a conflation that happens um
between two very different things one is
actual interactions between black people
and jewish people
and then of course we have to confront
the fact that there are black jewish
people
um so there's the actual meetings
between black people and jewish people
in the united states
in this overdetermined way that that
anthony um
has already lived for you and then
there's the the kind of
um cultural imaginary the all the work
we do
to um construct the idea that somehow
black people and jewish people
share some really consequential
similarities now let me just start with
black jewish relations because that's a
phrase that i think most of the people
who are on this
call probably are familiar with you
wouldn't come to a talk like this if you
didn't
know that black jewish relations is a
thing um and has some weight in american
cultural history and political history
and economic history
legal history but it wasn't always a
thing with that name
and so one of the things i want to do is
sort of is just going to unpack
that name a little bit black jewish
relations um because my sense is that we
don't really
have that as a common phrase as a way of
talking about these actual
um interactions until the 1950s or 1960s
i mean it gets going in the 1950s
but it really takes off in the 1960s and
one of the interesting things to note
is that it takes off because there's a
sense that develops particularly among
certain well-placed jewish people
that the relationship is falling apart
so there's a number of things that
happened in the 1960s
and i won't you know i don't want to
like create a whole archive of this now
in the limited time we have together
but i'll say a few obvious things um
there's um
a sort of clear recognition that the
kinds of alliances that brought
african-americans to choose um
together in the world of popular culture
in the world uh of uh um uh
jurisprudence legal work
um those things weren't happening with
the depth and the rapidity and
and the constancy um that they had
happened in that as had happened in the
1930s and 40s early 1950s
so there's this there's a few crises
that happen um in the 1960s i'll just um
locate one for now the ocean hill
brownsville um school crisis of the
1960s where
black parents are trying to gain control
of their local schools and the
the teachers union and i can't believe
i'm about to say something critical um
of the teachers union now that maury um
introduced me as
centering my own teachers union as as
crucial um uh to my
my work in the world right now but the
teachers union which was
um had a jewish leader and a very um uh
uh large population of jewish teachers
really resisted this because this felt
like an incursion
um on their professional control of the
schools and
it got ugly in a number of different
ways i don't want to go into all the
details of that but one of the things
that grew out of
that event and a number of other moments
of that kind of direct conflict
were symposia and lectures and books
and editorials and handwringing i mean
more than anything hand-wringing um and
and
and just about every one of these
symposiums
symposia and lectures was called
something like what went wrong
right it always had that that kind of
logic of inevitability
built into it right that the
relationship between african
americans and jews was somehow natural
so that brings me to the
relatedness part because the naturalness
was not necessarily
baked into the actual interactions the
naturalness
was baked into this sense of and again
i'm returning to anthony's initial
commentary the naturalness is built into
this sense that somehow blacks and jews
are deeply similar to each other
and it has its roots obviously in this
19th century
african-american adoption of certain
sacred jewish texts
but it also has 20th century um
iterations right the since that
african-american
jews um are the most musical people
uh in the united states that
african-americans and jews are the most
likely
uh most likely groups to be fighting for
social justice in the united states
so this thing that i'm calling the
cultural imaginary develops
which tells us that more than any other
non-white groups and i'm using that that
word non-white
really advisedly now and in a contingent
way and only really up until the early
1930s
um the sense that that african-american
jews are the two non-white groups sort
of most likely to find each other and
work together
whether it's in the music industry or
the civil rights uh movement
um uh creates sort of on top of it this
superstructure
um of of relatedness right and so i
really tried to push this idea that
there's a relatedness that's different
from the actual relation
now the problem um and i'm gonna stop
after for now
i'm gonna stop after i say this one last
thing is that it comes there comes a
moment where
the relations break down enough um that
the relatedness comes into question
as well um and i'll i'll timestamp that
sometime late 1960s early 1970s
and um we'll say that there's this other
thing that happens that we'll need to
talk about which is that
up until the 1950s african americans and
jews tended to live really close to each
other
um i'm sitting here in boston so i'm
thinking about roxbury
mattapan um i know a lot of you are
sitting um in new haven so if you think
about the closeness of
um let me see if i get this right i'm
trying to remember westville to
new hallville um neighborhoods in new
haven which are you know largely jewish
african-american
um if you think that new york you know
think about harlem uh
and the succession of african-americans
um coming after jews
um and and there's this this very sort
of everyday
um contact that african-american jews
have which kind of supports this idea
of relatedness but that and that really
begins to end in the 1950s as
um jews take part in what we have called
white flight
um and jews who are living um in urban
areas like roxbury and like harlem
um uh uh and you know sort of pick your
neighborhood in the city that you're
interested in
um they're not there anymore they leave
traces behind
because they still are involved in
businesses um in those places and that
makes things
even more complicated that the jewish
presence in a lot of that neighborhood
is now simply as merchants or as
landlords
um uh uh and and that makes it really
complicated to
imagine that african-american
african-americans and jews are simply
together the same alike so i'm going to
step back there and see if anthony wants
to jump back in
mute it again it looks like they're
unmuting us
one at a time yeah but yeah got it
so this concept of um an inherent
relatedness becomes endlessly
complicated and problematic when one
examines how much
agency black people have had in this
rhetorical relationship
and how much material good this
relationship has actually rendered
them um it becomes really problematic
when one considers how these narratives
of connection so easily become a
platform
for concrete and established
recrimination
whenever black people fall outside of
the invisible boundaries of what is
supposed to be a familial connection
the pain and the feelings
of betrayal that arise in the hearts of
jewish observers
of patterns of anti-semitic thinking in
parts of the black community
i think these feelings of betrayal are
familial
actually in nature how can you
a version of myself indulge in thinking
that potentially undermines yourself
rather uh you as a version
of myself and i think this
unusual kind of i think you said
cultural imaginary sort of relationship
imbues a lot of the rhetoric that
the monolithic jewish community
has in relationship to the monolithic
black community
but not always vice versa
i'm willing to bet jeffrey is probably
trying to unmute himself at the moment
yeah um i don't um and i don't put
anyone on the spot here but if you're
saying since
we're gonna try to actually have a
conversation here because any chance we
can both be um
on the mic at the same time it looks
like maybe we are now um that'd be great
thank you so much
um so yeah to i want to um sort of pick
up on on the last thing anthony said
and run with it a little bit um this
idea and that
it brings us obviously to the um title
of this this seminar and
um the purpose of our visit today that
this idea that there's a very
particular kind of black anti-semitism
um is is a question that i think anthony
and i both you know sort of wrestle with
in
uh our conversations are thinking about
this and and i think he
he said something really important i
just want to unders underscore it and
maybe extend it a little bit
um the idea that if there's any black
disagreement or black distance
from a jewish organization or a jewish
movement or a jewish production that
that's seen as a kind of betrayal and
not
just distance disinterest um um
you know um uh uh agency is the word
anthony used and
that seems perfect and so there is this
problem with black jewish
relations as it's usually constituted um
which is and this is really tricky to
talk about
i want to paraphrase something adolf
reed wrote in his book
about jesse jackson because jesse
jackson of course is one of those
those kinds of african-americans who
when he
did something that was um construed and
i i don't like i don't necessarily want
to relitigate that whole case but like
when he when he said him down and
and there was this question about
whether jesse jackson uh was
anti-semitic
um there was this went on this
conversation went on for years
and the question that some jews finally
got to was
does it really show the fact that he
even knows the word jaime
as a slur of jews does it show that
somehow he really is family that he is
in close
right because that right and so one of
the things adolf reid
underscored in his book about jesse
jackson
in one chapter where he was talking
about the sort of black anti-semitism
question
is that one of the problems with black
jewish relations is that very often it's
a conversation
that white jewish people want to steer
from both sides
right they want to say their peace but
they also on some level want to
ventriloquize what african americans
should be saying and doing
right there's the agency question again
and so i'm really
it's really uncomfortable to talk about
because it does play into some it does
play into some bad
the the analysis of this plays into some
bad
old anti-semitic images of jews as well
jesus as puppet masters you know sort of
controlling the discourse
um this bengali you know um kind of
construct
but it's a really important question to
ask right because one of the things that
in black jewish relations
we always talk about is that jews were
there for african-americans they were
there at the founding of the naacp
they were there on the legal team um uh
in the brownfire sport bed
uh discussion they were there obviously
um in in the
um uh uh you know in the um uh enrolling
voters drive in mississippi in 1964
right these these are sacred texts of
black jewish relations um and and one of
the problems with the way we talk about
that whole history is that it becomes
impossible to figure out where sort of
the jewish contribution
begins and ends because it becomes sort
of like
the the it becomes the water yeah it's a
it's a communal property
it becomes a communal property perfect
yeah
yeah and it's it's a problematic
communal property because what it does
is it conflates the actions
of a statistically
small amount of very brave individuals
who decided to actually move against
the tide of where um
american the american jewish community
was socially
and to show up on behalf of black people
for the purpose of racial equality
and what has happened of course in
intervening years
is that their actions have been
conflated
with the entire american jewish
community
and what that has created is
a rhetoric of indebtedness
that black people have
in relationship to the jewish community
and
i think it's really important for me to
say and for people to hear that this
is an unfortunate platform on which
to build any sort of solidarity around
issues
of anti-semitism and
acting on anti-blackness uh
right black people in the united states
already have and continue to have a very
unfortunate experience with uh rhetorics
of indebtedness
you'll see this crop up in any number of
spaces where
people have decided that actually it was
a good thing
that entire populations of africans were
brought to the united states because
um pick your period they found jesus
that would be a very 19th century sort
of version of that idea
maybe later they became acquainted with
western society and culture to their
benefit
um you can go on twitter right now and
find somebody who's probably saying
something to this degree
if you hadn't come to the united states
you would be in ethiopia and you'd be
starving
or you would be a child soldier given
that
um so much of the rhetoric around black
people
in the united states has come from a
place of
indebtedness a rhetoric and a politics
of indebtedness in relationship to a
response to anti-semitism
is undermining and is not sustainable
and does not build the kind of
solidarity that is needed
to address patterns of anti-semitic
thinking
in the black community if i could talk
about a community and a complete
monolith in the way that one
almost has two in these kinds of
conversations
right that's brilliant yeah i mean the
just the the very familiarity we have
with the phrase
black anti-semitism you know james
baldwin decades ago 50 years ago
um was was trying to remind us that that
you know if black people are
anti-semitic
it's because they're anti-white and
that's something like a lot of jews
don't like to hear right because
it it upsets a certain jewish narrative
of marginalization
of kind of special um kind of community
place that's not
not not purely white but that
indebtedness is a real problem because
it it
plunges us all of us into these
situations where black people
in this very ritual narrow ritualized
narrow way
where black people are sort of urged you
know
um pushed encouraged to pick your verb
um to apologize for other black people
um for
bad black people um and that's a really
bad ritual that i think we really need
to sort of think harder about
right um and this comes up you know i
i'm old enough that i feel like i can
sort of track
the cycles of every five years some
mainstream black leader has to disavow
louis farrakhan
and it's like you know that's something
we need to get past right because lewis
farrakhan
really important has a lot of followers
um but he just he's not at the heart of
mainstream black experience in the
united states
good luck trying to make that case
though um
i think i think there are people in the
american jewish community who think we
have pictures of farrakhan on the wall
like he's the lubavitcher rebbe and it's
just not like
it's not like that um i think there are
spaces in the black community in which
his leadership is looked on
with a certain amount of dubiousness and
derision
um it's
i have a lot of problems with kind of um
the formation and mobilization of a
monolithic concept like black
anti-semitism because i don't think it's
helpful
or particularly uh effective
uh against fighting patterns of
anti-semitic thinking in parts of the
black community
um establishing a phenomena of
anti-semitism in
ethnic terms gives it the dimensions of
something that is intrinsic
to that ethnicity as if right
each black person looks an innate
anti-semite who must be tamed exercised
right
right um the concept of black innocence
anti-semitism makes any semitism not
into an idea
or a prominent person or persons who is
disseminating these ideas among the
black community
but rather it turns uh patterns of
anti-semitic thinking into an amorphous
phenomenon which
while rhetorically useful actually
undermines the potential to address and
dismantle
patterns of anti-semitic thinking um
black anti-semitism is much more useful
as a phrase and as a rhetorical device
than it is as a way of actually fighting
patterns of anti-semitic thinking that's
right
that's right and that i mean just for
you know for our purposes today to try
to start focusing on
this thing we call black jewish
relations i was i was thinking back to
moments in my own sort of scholarly life
when
when there were these eruptions um of of
um
of of of mourning of of worry about
black jewish relations about
black anti-semitism and one of the major
ones and i'm sure many people on this
call remember
were the crown heights riots of 1991 um
which again without getting into the
granular details of
brought into conflict haasis
and a black community in brooklyn that
was largely west indian
right and that came to stand for in this
you know synagogue way i got that word
right
for all of black jewish relations two
very
marginal communities for each group
right
west indian mostly immigrant population
who came to stand for
black people in the u.s and has said who
can stand for jews hostages have not
been in the black jewish relations game
you know um that we've been outlining
for this history right like they just
get plunged
into that narrative in that moment
because they're sort of obviously
visibly jewish
um and that's something you know as a
historian i always wanted to try to
bring to the table and say like
when we're talking about black jewish
relations it at least let us try to
specify and anthony was trying to do
that before when he was
sort of reminding us that it's a very
small percentage of particular
kind of politically engaged jewish
people who have been involved
in that main you know sort of historical
activity uh of civil rights work it's a
very small
um uh uh group of jewish people who
um were you know um involved with the
sort of you know the key legal cases of
the night
you know like 40 early 50s so so that's
the thing i want to remind us of is is
to sort of think about
who we're trying to catch in this net
when we cast this net called black
jewish relations
i i'd like to bring up the fact that
um usually um in
evocations of the golden age of black
jewish relations of course
rabbi abraham joshua heschel always
makes
a starring appearance i've
had the the virtue and the pleasure of
knowing his daughter
susanna eschel who was an amazing
scholar
and over shabbos dinner we were talking
about this very subject and she said
very directly
that if you aren't doing
the work of creating racial justice
in this country you don't get to name
check her father
which means that a lot of
rhetoric that has been created
around this issue would instantaneously
disappear
because oftentimes um this affinity
that these two groups have for each
other is often expressed in terms that
are
either approaching or have surpassed the
half century
mark what do you do with
an affinity when it's about two
generations
back right that's a great question
that's a great question um i just want
to um note and i don't know
um if it's time or not that it that
we're a little past 5 30 and i don't
know if there's questions coming up
um in the chat yet because it's hard for
me to see where they are um and i know
that i know that anthony and i
um can keep going um until um you know
somebody says end meeting
um but i also want to make sure that
we're going to leave enough time for
other people to get into the
conversation
you guys can uh this is more talking you
guys can keep going for a little while
longer and then i'll join okay
you'll keep jumping okay great okay just
wanted to check on that um
so um you know one of one of the things
i'm i'm gonna i want to put
another term into the conversation that
i feel like we've been dancing around
um but haven't quite said which is class
um and
we're we're not gonna be able to able to
have a forthright conversation about
this thing called
so-called black anti-semitism or black
jewish relations more generally without
talking about the very different class
trajectories
um of white shoes and african americans
in the united states right that that um
maybe it goes without saying um but it's
one thing i was trying to index when i
talked a little bit about white flight
um which is this this period and this
formation
um that we call that we we try to
capture with this name black jewish
relations
is really rooted in this time when um
americans used were
city people um and were you know sort of
work you know working across the lower
middle class
and we're in this moment now where the
class differential um
between uh white jews and african
americans in the united states is so
stark
um that it's almost impossible to sort
of have the conversation without at
least noting
that the two communities it's more than
two communities obviously but but for
the shorthand two communities are living
and
literally living in very different
places um they're
they're occupying very different
vocations i know i'm painting with a
very broad going
in very broad strokes right now um but
but there is an
and i feel like anthony was sort of
outlining this a little bit before this
idea
that blacks and jews aren't so different
from each other not only they're not so
different but there's this kind of like
amazing cultural energy um that
that convinces us that that they're
almost the same
um and that's really dangerous to my
mind
it makes it impossible um for african
americans to kind of find good spaces in
u.s
culture as speaking subjects um telling
their own stories and not telling a
story that that's kind of like
that we always that we know already um
that's already been scripted
i think it's very easy to kind of want
to um it's very easy for people to want
to have a discussion about
jews in the united states in a
relationship to assimilation
into greater american culture
but i think what is not often discussed
is
that in order to do that there was a
pre-existing racial hierarchy that
either had to be passively or
actively accepted um
as almost
the fair for kind of arriving
into full american assimilation and
a lack of engagement with that i think
as
a community um or really with that as an
idea
once again undermines the ability
for these two communities so i can speak
about these two people in a
monolith like we have to throughout this
conversation it undermines
the ability for us to have an uh
historically honest conversation
about where we have been where we could
possibly go
as far as um joining each other
and the work of creating racial equality
in this country
okay i'm i'm gonna jump in here because
we do have a bunch of
uh questions from people and i would
just ask i noticed that some people have
raised their hand
but um since i can't call on people if
you could type your questions in the q
a uh so if you see that little q a
button at the bottom
you can type questions there and i will
ask the the panelists so we have a bunch
of questions this is really such a
a fascinating conversation and and i
think we're all just so grateful
uh to both of you for your you know
thoughtfulness
uh about these issues so one question
that that i had and that i see also that
um some of the
um uh people in the audience have had is
i think people were
a little bit puzzled by something you
said jeff about how
jews weren't really white until the
1930s
or maybe weren't seen as white and we're
wondering if you could just
say something about um how jews became
white did
did black people ever not see jews as
white um did um uh
you know how do we parse this idea of
jews as almost
white but not quite white enough for
white america
yeah great i mean that's thank you
anybody who's thinking about that and
asking the question thank you maury for
putting it on the table
um you know jewish whiteness uh is a
really complex historical question
um i've written about it i see at least
two other people on the call who have
written
uh about it as i scroll down and i'm
sure pro more um
some folks who maybe i don't know um so
this is something that historians
really got interested in 1980s 1990s
definitely earlier as well and and
there's this sort of clear sense that at
least until the 1920s jews occupied some
kind of middle space
jews are not the only not sort of
distinct group in the u.s
um we've got great historians of
italian-american life great historians
of
um uh of uh our you know armenian
american life
who tried to parse this question now
what do we do about these groups that
um immigrated um as part of the great
wave
uh starting in the 1880s of what we you
know generally called new immigration
um and we're not anglo-american and jews
were clearly among the eastern european
jews um in particular the
the german jews who came earlier a
little bit of a different story but
eastern european jews were
definitely seen as a distinct population
up through the 20s there was plenty of
people
um anthropologists politicians
journalists
who were still referring to jews as a
race right that's obviously like not an
understanding
that we have now jews and the process by
which jews
stop being publicly recognized a race
it's obviously not overnight we can't
put a year on it
we can you know make a we can put some
frames around it right we can certainly
say
um that by the 1930s 1940s as jews are
sort of moving up the economic ladder
certainly as news of the genocide um in
europe starts
making its way to the united states in
the 1950s
it kind of helps frame this idea that
jews need to be sort of like
we need to underscore the safety of jews
in the united states and part of the
safety
is understanding jews um as white people
and then really i think with the
suburbanization of the 1950s
um it becomes impossible to think of
jews as anything other than um
just another what you know what in the
1960s and 70s we started
more uh frequently referring to as an
ethnic group
right um and so jews are like italians
or like irish or like you know
um uh various other hyphenated groups uh
that are clearly white
you know this holds for immigrant groups
up until basically 1965 when the
immigration law
changes and there's a huge wave of
people from latin america
asia the caribbean africa and so on who
are hyphenated americans and clearly not
not white in american terms
so that's a quick answer i could go on
but yeah um
no that's great that's um uh
another question um from someone is uh
how someone who who grew up in the south
and
is you know wondering about whether uh
we can say that
jews in the south adopted uh the
prejudice of
white non-jewish southerners and so i
think we can say you know
where most jews came from they probably
didn't have many opinions of black
people at all
and so how did can we trace that kind of
history
of anti-black prejudice among jews
how would we call that story in the
historical record
you find many proofs of
a general amount of bafflement from um
the southern jewish community in the
face of all of these northerners who
came
over the course of of mississippi summer
because to a certain extent they
had already figured out um
in decades and centuries uh previous
what their specific place was in the
racial hierarchy of the american south
and they knew that
that level of interaction with black
people
put that in peril so
there is that i mean that is a part of
the historical record is that all of
these
you know jews from the north came and
the jews in the south were like who are
these people what are they doing what is
this about
right and i should just say actually one
of the
people in the audience pointed out that
of course um you know
uh white people are jews have had the
the the privilege of choosing whether to
be white in this to a certain extent you
know and whether to
do that which is interesting so here's
another question from
from the audience um what about the role
of um
black jews um and this is something
maybe a question
um anthony so um you know we have of
course you know the kind of celebrity
examples like sammy davis jr but also
you know there may be more
problematically like the the black
israelite
movement and things like that how should
we think about those groups
question really for both of you
i think as far as black israelites are
concerned it's
complicated because it in that case it
really is
i think quite directly an appropriation
of
um jewish religiosity
as a form of religious expression
um and i think there's a lot of
different aspects of uh
black diasporic history that go into
that sort of um impulse to appropriate
very directly um this way of
of expressing oneself religiously um
it's very hard for me to actually figure
out how that that fits in and it's
something about which
i am a freedom a little ignorant
it's something that i've been meaning to
learn more about just because it's
interesting
in general but i don't know in a way
it seems like um
a sort of fulfillment an embodiment
of this idea of the paradigm but it goes
off into such a very
definitive direction that i think um in
many ways
um if they're not looked on um
with hostility they're looked on with a
great amount of curiosity
um as a bizarre in relationship to
the normative aspects of you know
american judaism
right and i'll just showing that
obviously mainstream white shoes are not
particularly interested in black jews
um of any kind um there's not like a
huge community outreach
uh effort to bring to open up
conversations with the more fringe
groups or to bring in
um and that's part obviously of jewish
you know jews not being like a
converting
um uh people but but but you know that's
there too
i mean there's i i just want to just
quickly go back to the question about
excuse in the south
since i have a particular interest there
um in an earlier era than than what
anthony was talking about
um which is that most of the jews in the
south um in the
pre-world war ii era are german jews and
they're
to use to borrow a word that they
wouldn't have used um because it's a
more eastern european uh english kind of
word they were all right nicks i mean
they were
really satisfied with their position by
and large
as quasi-white people or apprentice
white people
um and and that's a really that made for
a really complicated map in
in in moments of crisis when um you know
and obviously i wrote a book about the
leo frankie so that's a moment of real
crisis
where um jews make great efforts to try
to demonstrate
to the white people around them that
they are
really better than black people and
really more trustworthy and safer
and all that yeah of course there's also
the
the israeli dimension to this question
which i don't think we want to get into
today but of course
who's gone to israel and you see that
there are a lot of
you know um jews from ethiopia there and
that obviously is
a whole other thing so here's a question
um for jeff
from matt jacobson who's um written a
lot about these
questions and he wants to know you know
how
he says that the idea of black
anti-semitism really controlled
the space of the 1990s um and but here
we are
in this very different moment in 2020
uh in a moment of kind of frank white
nationalism
uh and we really have no narrative to
suture these moments together can you
kind of maybe
uh try to do that or maybe narrate your
own position
in relation to these two moments as a
scholar that's great i mean i
think thanks matt for the question um
and i'd like to bring you know anthony
on answering it too because that's sort
of like recent history that we're both
trying to parse right now
um and the there's still the sort of
over familiarity and as you were asking
i was trying to remember who the
celebrity was who had
to go through recently this ritual of
apologizing
and he's teamed up with some rabbi who's
teaching him
how to really understand jews and i'm
blanking on who it was now you got it
it's nick cannon
the cannon of course right and so we
still have this ritual of
you know a black person saying something
i don't remember what mckenna said and
it was maybe awful i don't remember um
but we still have this ritual of
of um running the black anti-semitism
you know sort of cranking up the black
anti-semitism machine and then the
apologies and the learning and the
triumphant redemption tour um and it's
to me i i don't i mean i don't want to
sort of lapse into the vernacular here
in answering what's a very serious
question but it's not that we have not
developed a phrase
like evangelical anti-semitism
right or christian zionists christian
zionist anti-semitism
right like that's real in our world
right now not only is it real but it's
terrifyingly shaping of our national
politics
i'm gonna go ahead also i i think it's
really interesting of course i was
thinking about
kind of um the the sort of
history and trajectory of patterns of
anti-semitic thinking amongst the black
community and i think
what a lot of people don't often address
is the fact
that black people inherited
a millennia old system of
pre-existing christian
anti-semitic rhetoric which
many times is often present in the
anti-semitic thinking
um that is found in portions of the
black community
so we don't we don't call it christian
we need to do something about christian
anti-semitism
um but god forbid should a black leader
invoke the image of judas
immediately that is um apportioned to
his blackness
right not necessarily to his
christianity right
right i know let me throw one thing in
that i maybe i shouldn't but i'm going
to go ahead and do it anyway
um israel looms really large in this
contemporary conversation just to get
back to math question
um which is to say you know one of the
breaking points
in you know in the black jewish
relations narrative of the late 1960s is
that
many african-americans begin to see
their position in the united states as
having much more in common with
palestinians in the middle east
than with white jews in israel that's
obviously a real problem for a lot of
american jews right
now in our own moment christian zionists
who very often
are starkly anti-semitic in some of the
most traditional
terrible ways they're zionists
right they support the state of israel
as a jewish state and so they're off the
hook
with a huge swath of american jewry
who still support the idea of israel as
a as a jewish state so so the israel
question is really in this in some
complicated ways
and has been you know for for black
people
in the united states as a kind of
negative you know sort of check against
them right because there's this sentence
that develops in the late 60s early 70s
that black people are anti-israel all
right um and
in our own moment the the proponents of
the most dangerous anti-semitism in the
united states bar none
are people who support israel um and so
we're in this very
complicated um sort of religious racial
political moment
great so a question about
you know i would say that um you know
both uh
blacks and jews have this um
weight of a very difficult history
looming over them i mean both
feel that they were victims of unique
forms of oppression and rightly
so we have slavery on the one hand and
we have the holocaust on the other
and i think um i'm wondering if you can
say anything about um this kind of
almost like an implicit sense of
competition
among victims um and does that play into
the difficulties of the black jewish
paradigm
i think it's interesting that you
expressed um
[Music]
expressed is on the jewish side in terms
of the holocaust
because i think for a lot of
um communal and familial narratives
about the phenomenon of
jewish suffering it often predates
the holocaust um and
knowing and naming um the nature
of that systemic oppression usually by
the
russian empire is an important part of
formulating exactly what the narrative
is that connects black people and jews
i believe you are talking about um a
phenomenon that is
very colloquially called the oppression
olympics absolutely
on twitter that we should get used to
the oppressive olympics because
it's going to be the only olympics that
are going to be happening for a long
time
i
i jeffrey would you like to yeah yeah i
mean i'll jump in i just happen to have
this book
sitting right near me and i don't know
if you can see um
tony martin's beloved which came out in
1987 and i don't know who on the call
will remember this but there was a huge
well it's a huge but there was a a
legible
jewish respond negative response to the
book
because of the epigraph and i'll read it
um because it's short
um the the first thing you you read in
the book that toni morrison wrote
is 60 million and more
so simple you know she's
opening the book she's clearly making
this move to try to get our our
attention to the middle passage
um and putting a number on uh the number
of people who
uh perished as a result of the middle
passage and
it's because she said 60 and you how you
people will have to trust me on this if
you haven't heard this before
um there was a there was an outcry in
certain corners of the jewish community
that she was trying to sort of outdo the
6 million
in a major scale right by saying the 60
million and so this is like a real
this is a really structuring formation
in black jewish relations
um is that jews always want to keep
certain jews want to keep present
and i'll i'll just say it because this
is a particular political concern of
mine
um that to me is the work in our own
time of the anti-defamation league
right um which is involved in a lot of
business but one of the main
things they're involved with is keeping
present this idea
that jews in the united states live
always every day
an incredibly fraught experience
and in in doing so they very often are
put in the position
of having to elbow out african-american
claims to that same kind of status
um okay i'm gonna i'm gonna go there and
i'm gonna bring the
the discussion to what we were talking
about right before we started and what i
think is
uh tragically on a lot of people's minds
right now which is
rbg um and you know we're all
you know experiencing that loss right
now and
but you know it's an interesting uh
thing that very
term rbg is you know arguably an
appropriation or not even arguably an
appropriation from african-american
culture and
i'm wondering if um i know that you two
i'm not really wondering i i know that
you
have something to say about um
the way that um we she has been uh
lionized in our in the culture right now
is being
uh and whether that uh what that is
enabling and also maybe what that
is um repressing
ever so briefly i'd like to address the
fact that
um giving the judge this moniker
this kind of cutesy moniker um as
a sort of campaign of valorization
is very indicative of the fact that
there's a point in american history and
contemporary history where
um valorization was decided was much
more interesting
and much more easy to do than civic
action
um in a way we could outsource
the kind of civic action that we were
supposed to be doing
um to these um kind of elevated actors
um if i mean jeffrey's had
kind of really interesting and very
multi-layered things to say around the
construction
of a concept like the notorious rbg
um yeah i'm happy
i'm happy to i'm happy to jump in at
least briefly on that because i've been
tangling
um with people on on social media for a
couple days
um about this i'm worried that i've lost
my connection so i'm gonna try to
reconnect
okay i got it i'm okay all right um
okay so just to tell me in the chat box
if you lose me on my internet
connections being a little weird
so the the idea that you take this
jurist this
short white jewish woman and make a meme
out of her you know put
um christopher wallace notorious vig's
crown on her
um i can't help but try to read it in in
in the history
of the jewish presence in minstrelsy i'm
not putting this on ginsberg herself
obviously i don't think she had much to
do
with her own mummification right this is
people around her it was invented
originally by a jewish
nyu law student who uh then co-wrote the
book notorious
rbg the the children's book um and so
this is a jewish you know
it's a it's a white jewish production um
and it's
it's impossible for me not to see it as
the humor
to sort of the putative humor in it as
being in the distance between
the brilliant you know white jurist and
the street rapper from from brooklyn um
now there are i just want to be fair
there's plenty of people who are saying
like no it was honoring both of them it
was saying that in their fields they
were both
you know tough talkers you know like
you know you know didn't get into this
or conventional expectations and all
that
but i'm a historian you know and i got
to read it in history and there is this
legible history
um of jewish people pretending to be
black
um and it's a really important history
and it's i mean it's my whole first book
obviously i care about it um this
question of how
jews because exactly because of their
closeness to black people
claimed a special ability to write black
music to perform black music to
promote black music and later on when
jews sort of stepped out of the
central world to be you know the the
record label owners and the producers
and so on
so there's like a history here that i
think is impossible to ignore
um when we think about the notorious rgb
um the
the the conversation i've been in has
been fascinating
um and particularly interesting to see
all the
um african-american people who have
jumped into the conversation to say
oh yeah that's that that's that that
everyone knows that's been bad for a
long time and i wasn't aware like i
didn't i
i feel open-ended because i wasn't aware
that there was a whole conversation
already
about it okay um
so you know a couple people have um
noted that
you know uh or have wondered whether um
you know this the black jewish relations
paradigm is it only really something
in the past or can we talk about
um moments or or points of convergence
today you know one of them being for
instance that
that blacks and jews are you know two of
the most
um uh loyal groups within the democratic
party in fact their voting
records are pretty similar you know for
the for the most part
um and you know to try we only have a
couple minutes left so i think this is
going to be the last
question but um you know uh
is there um are there moments of
of kind of you know are there positive
things that we might look
towards today politically useful ways of
thinking about
um the black jewish uh relationship
you know uh today ever so briefly
without washing what's
what's wrong about it but yeah of course
um
ever so briefly i'd like to address the
fact that the reason why we even have
the ability to name
check the people who did take the uh
effort to align themselves
with nascent movements of
racial equality is because they
showed up in physical space they did not
show up in
rhetorical space they did not
release a concept record about what they
thought
their relationship was to black people
they did not write an essay
even though as an essayist i think it
still is important work to do that to
get those ideas out into the world
they showed up in physical american
space an american space in which um
where they were supposed to be in order
to retain
the status quo was very distinctly
written out
they crossed those boundaries they
crossed the imaginary boundaries
of what the america the american
jewish black relation was supposed to be
and they entered into physical space and
they showed up on behalf of black people
and i think as long as you are trying to
do that to the best of your ability
you will find yourself um
answering this question directly end
time and once again in american space
great i mean i i have almost nothing to
add
to that other other than you know if you
can join your union
um you know i'm just trying to think of
like literal street-level places where
african-americans and jews might still
come in contact and the growing union
movement
particularly teachers unions um
particularly trying to bring together
um uh you know sort of main classroom
teachers with para
professional teachers there's going to
be some like really interesting ways
that i think jews in particular will be
challenged to imagine
as i think anthony was just just really
hinting at
um imagining solidarity with black
people um that
that will mean jews showing up for
things that might not immediately
benefit them
um but that might be kind of just larger
social justice achievements that
jews care about um or should care about
right the civil rights movement
originally was not an overdetermined
phenomenon people did not know how it
was going to end right
um which makes the actions of jews in
that particular period
who were part of that movement even more
uh
valorous in my mind because this was
once again like a nascent movement
um there were not terms which were
dictated to the people who were in this
movement
um in order to assure
that they were going to join this
movement um
we really do have these models and if we
follow these models
in space if we show up like i said once
again we have answers to these questions
okay well i think we have to leave it
there at six o'clock
uh clearly this conversation could go on
a lot longer
and fortunately it will and i encourage
everyone to
tune in for our whole lecture series
this semester which again you can find
on the
ypsa yipsa website um
and um my apologies to the uh people who
ask questions that i didn't get to
to ask um they were really fascinating
questions and i thank the audience
but uh let's all give our special thanks
to
jeff and anthony um one of the downsides
of the webinar format is that they can't
hear you
but um i will clap for everybody so
thank you very very much um uh
for this really really stimulating
conversation so
thank you so much for having us thank
you really thank you everybody for
showing up
great great to see your names at least
really appreciate it
thanks take care